welcome back to the games with stage
here at e3 2015 joining me once more is
Ali rapper Nintendo treehouse hello how
was your three going stay tuned ow day
two I'm starting to get a little bit of
like the weirds yeah like I say what
it's wheels
tomorrow is gonna be even weirder so be
prepared for some bonkers things coming
out of my mouth I have you on the stage
again tomorrow so just be warning me
it's gonna be wacky yeah what have you
brought for me today we are gonna show
off some Yoshi's woolly world and I am
so happy yeah see right here table we
have the Yoshi amiibo and I just had a
little hook with it
and I just had a little hook with it oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so soft
I just I want it oh yeah and you guys
take his little NFC is in his butt which
is one of my favorite parts because I
mean it's just so different yeah yeah
there's no like there's no hard piece on
the bottom it's just like a little buddy
you can squeeze in love he's really cute
and if I wasn't plumbed in like the bulk
I'd be reaching over grabbing me - he's
great I said so many little about you
she's witty world yeah it's uh it's on
the screen here we can see it's being
demoed as we speak yep
it's just so adorable yeah it's pretty
sickening sickeningly adorable so it's
kind of obviously spring to mind is
kirby yep yeah Kirby's Epic Yarn Nobita
Gulliver yep and but how is here she's
pretty well a little different so you're
she's fully world and if you haven't
played like a Yoshi's Island game or any
of this other Yoshi games so the kind of
core concept of a Yoshi game play is
that there's no timer and the reason
that is is because there's so many
secrets in each of the world yes that
you really need as much time as you can
get to find all the collectables and
there's so many of them there's like the
smiley flowers there's the bead there's
the Wonder wool there are the stamp
patches so there's a lot of stuff to
find and what people I think are really
gonna like about Yoshi's woolly world is
that if you want to just kind of relax
like man this is so cute this is what
I'm gonna play at the end of my day
whenever
stress and I've been playing games all
day I've been sorting mail all day or
whatever you do you know it's gonna be
one of those relaxing experiences for
you that you can just kind of enjoy
there's mellow mode which is kind of
like an infinite flutter jump at the
same time if you're someone who is
really interested in a challenge and
doesn't want to feel like because it's
cute or because you know there is mellow
mode I'm gonna have a batter but it's
definitely not like that
yeah so if you're looking for a
challenge especially if you're one of
those people who likes to get
collectibles trust me when I say that
it's you're not gonna be disappointed
yeah yeah and you can play with a friend
yeah you can play I'm up to two players
and what's really cool about that is you
can use each other through the stages
right so like you can swallow you can
gobble up your buddy to use them as a
yarn ball like Stacey run out of yarn
ball like how you're using it in like
the nice cooperative sense right when in
reality that's not what right right you
can like
gobble gobble them up and like throw
them onto a Ledge or something and of
course you can you know throw them off
of ledges if you are so inclined but
then they come back and like this cute
little winged egg and one thing you can
do is let's see you sarah can hear me
you can tap amiibo umm like normal
amiibo and change them into a different
pattern of Yoshi so right now we're
seeing Donkey Kong Yoshi you can have
Mario Yoshi Samus Yoshi Fox Yoshi oh
that's so adorable but that being said
if you even if you don't have a me bow
you can still get different patterns so
what happens is there's something called
Wonder wool which is a collectible and
when you collect some of those you
unlock different Yoshi patterns so you
don't necessarily need a me bow to
experience that kind of fun you know
little costume changing aesthetic and do
that I mean I think the Yoshi amiibos
are gonna go like that like I mean
they're already gone I'm really excited
hiking that one yeah yeah yeah this
one's mine
um so with the Yoshi amiibo itself the
yarn Yoshi amiibo what that does is if
you're in single-player you tap the yarn
Yoshi amiibo and you get what's called
double Yoshi
and wo she is basically it's like
multiplayer you have a second Yoshi on
screen but it's kind of an AI that's
being controlled by whatever you're
doing with your main Yoshi so it's a
huge jump 'i'm the powerup and shoot my
bros we use Oh like a double cherry
tapping yeah yeah yeah so if you jump
the other Yoshi jumps if you you know
run forward the other Yoshi runs forward
so in some ways it makes it like oh well
you know if I fall off a ledge my other
Yoshi maybe was further back and it's
ledge so I can we come back but at the
same time you're controlling to Yoshi so
it can also be a fun challenge it's so
that's double Yoshi and that's what the
yarn Yoshi [ __ ] what I think's really
cool about this game is that not only is
it accessible in terms of gameplay it's
accessible in terms of controllers that
you have like it's really pushing the
boat out in terms of accepting pretty
much everything right right now we're
playing with via with the Wii U gamepad
in the regular Wii Remote well of course
you know what we always make a full list
of all the controllers you can use but
yeah I mean if you've got like a whole
bunch of Wii Remote sitting at home and
you're just you normally you play on
your gamepad but you've got a buddy
coming over hook him up one other cool
thing about that is say that you want to
play two player and say that you're
really good at games and say that your
buddy maybe isn't what's fun is that
even if you don't want to go into mellow
mode what you can do is say that there's
like a Ledge or a gap that they can't
make because maybe they're just bad at
flutter jumping or whatever dude I know
you were doing a pipe I was like what
you can like gobble them up as a yarn
ball I'll hurry them over the ledge and
then spit them back out so I mean you're
literally carrying them yeah you
literally yeah so it's a great way to
just kind of explore with your friends
no matter if they're a really skilled
player yeah in which case you should be
able to find out your maybe final
collectibles or even if they're not a
skilled player on this look a little bit
on the world everything is niches yeah
everything is kind of like handicraft so
you see lots of like knitted stuff you
see like phelp do you see buttons you
see rhinestones so you know we like to
say that the world is kind of made out
of yarn but really the world is made out
of like
crafting materials okay how about a
Sheree yeah yeah it's really really cool
it's not just the static - like for
example you'll be walking along and
you'll see like a loose thread so you'll
like you know you'll eat the loose
thread and then it'll turn into like a
little butterfly will float off and if
you follow the butterfly it'll lead you
to say collectibles or a new area or
something I noticed earlier as well like
water is just like a little stream oh
yeah yeah everything in the world is
that kind of handicraft aesthetic so
it's just like I heard someone when we
were showing it out last year I heard
someone say like Yoshi's woolly world is
the most photo-realistic game I've ever
played and I was like actually that
makes a lot of sense because it really
does like you actually do feel like
you're playing with little yarn and I
just I just kind of want to know when
Nintendo releasing the official Yoshi
knitting pattern oh that's a good idea
yeah I'm kind of collecting ideas and
we'll bring this back so I'll I'll let
you know if we we managed to pull that
off but yeah that'd be sweet we talked
about in the digital event like the the
lady and the dev I can't member her name
she was talking about like making her
own Yoshi and I remember like oh that's
a really good idea to have one of them
yeah so let's talk let me know what's
happening on screen yeah yeah
so Yoshi's kind of walking around right
Le'Veon yes so we're seeing that
butterfly mentioned where they pulled a
loose thread they find this butterfly
who then leads you to another area and
that area wouldn't been accessible have
that butterfly knock on there because
you saw he attached himself like to a
wall and then you pulled the butterfly
again and the wall disappeared you could
get the smiley flower yeah
but otherwise you know we're just kind
of seeing that kind of really like core
Yoshi gameplay where you've got your
flutter jumps you've got
exploring areas that are usually hidden
um you've got a lot of enemies that
return but of course you know maybe some
enemies that you haven't seen before
yeah it's really awesome there's also
these big yarn balls it looks like Sarah
may have used a power badge so what
happens is you're collecting these beads
and it's not like those you can use them
to purchase power badges so you can play
alongside poochy I was a little dog from
the you know
nope nope nope novices character you can
make all your yarn balls big and big
yarn balls can hit up to like three
times so it can like bounce off of stuff
and hit another thing and then there's
also stamp patches in the game and stamp
patches are kind of like red coins in
previous Yoshi's gay hour Yoshi games
where every so often like he'll be
collecting beads and then you'll collect
a stamp patch when you collect so many
of those they'll turn into basically you
unlock a me burst am the game yeah yeah
so there's there's just so much stuff to
grab so like I said you know if if
you're looking for like a chill
experience you've got that if you're
looking for like a really scary
experience you got that - yeah
I mean how can you kind of keep track of
all collectibles is there some kind of
compendium and yeah so at the end of
each stage we're actually seeing the end
right now what timing you'll see kind of
what you collected in that in that stage
you know we haven't really seen much of
like the overworld menu yet but I
imagine that there will be some way to
like when you scroll over the stage feel
to see yeah you know they're always
wasn't previous Island games or you know
Yoshi games in general so I imagine the
third be some way because collectibles
is like tons of what it makes Yoshi game
so you can't help yourself when you do
it either
just one more yeah like you get to the
end like I knew I've been playing that
back course that's supposed to be like
the easy course on the show floor like
if you haven't played Yoshi gamer if you
want to get adjusted the controls I've
played it probably a dozen times and
still have not found all the smiley
particulate so either I'm really bad at
Yoshi games or I mean what I say when it
is gonna be hard to find all of them
well it's out very soon isn't it it's
out in October October yeah yeah kind of
soon 20 Rosie's right right yeah um so
it's a little bit of a wait for some
folks but it is like it's so so amazing
and I'm just I'm well I you know I think
it's amazing it's a lot of fun and I
really hope that people have a lot of
fun with it too and I think they will
hope they will I'm sure they will do in
October Ali thank you so much for
joining me
so this is my last slot on today's stage
coming up next with Danny O'Dwyer he'll
be showing off some awesome games make
sure you don't go anywhere
this is games one at e3 2015
you